Speaker 1: It's great to welcome to the program,
Tom Standage, who is deputy editor of The
Economist and also author of the book, A Brief
History of Motion From the Wheel to the Car
to What Comes Next Time.
It's great to have you on today.
Really appreciate it.
Speaker 5: Thanks very much for having me.
Speaker 1: You know, I'm actually reading
right now the book Fourteen Ninety One.
And one of the interesting anecdotes in it
is about how was it that so few Spaniards
were able to defeat these these large armies
of of Inca and other groups in what is now
Central America?
And one of the things that's mentioned was
the superior understanding and use of the
wheel in all of its different forms by by
the Spanish.
And although I wasn't reading that because
I was going to be interviewing you, I think
the importance of the wheel and ultimately
of automobiles, it really cannot be overstated
in terms of its impact on human society and
culture, can it?
Speaker 5: Well, I think that's true, but
I also think it's very easy to overlook.
So, for example, someone once said that if
you're a fish, right, you're swimming around
in water all the time.
But fish have no concept of what water is
because they're just surrounded by it.
They just assume that's that's the way the
world is.
And I think we're sort of the same with cars.
We we live in a world that has been shaped
by cars and we can't imagine it really being
any other way.
So what I'm trying to do with this book is
sort of point out the water to the fish and
say, how do we get here and how bright things
are different?
And if we all going to be less reliant on
cars of the future and I think we probably
are, then, you know, it's helpful to see if
we're going to start unpicking cars from the
fabric of our civilization and from everyday
life, that it's useful to see how it was woven
in.
So that's really what I'm what I'm trying
to do.
Do you see what the other factor we should
mention, of course, was disease?
I mean, the fact that indeed the Europeans
took that is contagious.
I'm sure that the wheel played a role.
The other thing is that American cultures
were aware of the wheel but generally didn't
use it.
It was it was used in some toys.
This is one of the striking things.
You know, the wheel is a great cliche about
the wheel.
Is it the greatest invention in history and
this sort of thing?
But basically, just how many cultures knew
about it but didn't use it?
Another example would be the Egyptians who
managed to build the pyramids entirely without
using wheels.
They knew about wheels because the Mesopotamians
next door had them.
But the Egyptians just found it much easier
to move things around on rafts on the Nile
and Roller's, the fact there was no wheeled
vehicle on Earth that could have taken a block
they would use to build the pyramid, it was
just those pyramid blocks are really, really
big and heavy.
So.
So this idea that wheels are the greatest
together is a very recent idea.
It's a sort of early 20th century idea, and
it's at the point where we're reshaping the
world around wheeled vehicles that we decide
that actually wheels are totally awesome.
But that's a relatively recent way of looking
at things.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I, I think sometimes it's
missed by lots of people that in cities, towns,
villages, I mean in much of what is when I
say the developed world, I don't even mean
the West, but just even parts of any country.
That is what we would consider developed at
all the amount of the planning and and surface
area that is geared around prioritizing wheeled
vehicles over for walking.
And that unless you think about it, it may
not be apparent to many people
Speaker 5: that, well, it's it's more of I
mean, obviously most most recognizable in
the US, which has these laws about, you know,
if you build a new retail development, you
have to have a certain number of car parking
spaces.
Right.
By one estimate, there's six parking spaces,
I think, for every car in the US.
So, I mean, that's at about 30 percent of
the area of a typical US city is parking.
So, I mean, it's it's amazing how much space
is is is given over to vehicles.
And I think one of the big stories that I
really found was struck by what I was researching.
The book was the extent to which this this
handing over of so much space to the car is
a very recent thing.
It's only happened in the past hundred years.
I mean, even if you look at photographs of
streets from, say, 1910 in Europe and the
US, you don't see parked cars along the side
of the street.
And then and you also see if you look at film
from the early 20th century, there's a very
famous film going down in San Francisco in
about, I think, its first decade of the 20th
century just before the big earthquake.
And and it's amazing that you've got all these
different kinds of vehicles and people weaving
in and out of each other.
Yeah, I think you got this big change where
they the car drivers say, well, no, this is
slowing us down.
Everyone else needs to get out of the way.
Roads are for cars.
They're definitely not for pedestrians.
They're definitely not for coastal vehicles.
Frankly, we don't much like streetcars either
because they get in the way.
And so the supremacy of the car really becomes
a thing at that point.
And, you know, nowadays, you know, if you
stand in the middle of the road, you're an
idiot.
Karl is going to hit you, of course it is.
What are you doing there?
But that's not the way streets used to work.
And again, this is something that we sort
of take for granted if we've grown up in a
world that's full of cars.
But that's not the way things were and it's
not the way things have to be.
And if you go to some parts of the world,
it's not like that.
And you do have much more of a sort of sharing
of street space and civility, even in some
Western countries have decided to take back
some of that space from cars.
We've seen a lot of this in the pandemic,
but it was already happening in places like
Oslo and Helsinki, where quite a lot of the
city center spaces, car parking was given
to bike lanes, areas, pedestrian ised and
so on.
So I think we're trying to sort of rediscover
what less car centric world would look like.
Speaker 1: Yeah, and I think one of the there's
this kind of I don't know if it's a it's not
really a thought experiment.
There's this line that's often mentioned about,
you know, humans don't really know what comes
next and what the next advancement would be,
because if you asked the horse and buggy people
right before cars came to be what they wanted
for better transportation, they would say
a more reliable or a faster horse and buggy,
which which means they missed the possible
paradigm shift of cars.
Would that is a kind of framework when we
talk about electric vehicles, when we talk
about self-driving, etc., do you think that
we're even really talking about what the next
paradigm shifts will be in wheeled transportation,
or is it more likely about.
Speaker 5: Well, I think I think we're in
danger of falling into a historical trap.
So this book tells the story of wheel vehicles,
starting with the first wheels and then looking
at, you know, various attempts to make steam
powered vehicles and trains and bicycles.
And then you get to cars and cars kind of
take over.
And then I try to look at what's coming next,
but I start the book.
And the reason I think this this whole history
is worth looking at so much now by comparing
the current situation with the situation in
the 90s and in the 90s, it was it was becoming
apparent that the dependency that big, fast
growing cities had on the horse and horse
based transport was completely unsustainable.
So the population of horses in places like
that in New York was growing much faster than
the population of people.
And more and more horses per person were needed
to move goods and people around.
And railways made it worse because you have
more goods and people coming in and out of
cities.
And so the more you have those long distance
links, the more you need capacity within the
city to move people and goods around.
And so this was becoming recognized as a big
problem that was more about horse manure piling
up in the streets.
It was a big pollution problem.
It was a big health problem.
There were lots of lots of traffic jams.
It was very, very noisy.
There were accidents and so on and so on.
And so people were they realized this was
unsustainable, but they weren't sure what
was going to come next.
And then the the automobile was invented at
around this time.
It's been it's been in the works for actually
about a century or longer, depending on how
you look at it.
But the proponents of the automobile say it's
going to solve these problems.
You're not going to have horse manure.
You're not going to have traffic, because
taking away the the horse they're originally
called horseless carriages will mean that
these vehicles take up less space on the street
so they can move faster.
They're not going to make as much noise because
they've got rubber tires.
So the streets are going to be quieter and
there aren't going to be any accidents because
you haven't got horses to kind of kick people
or run away.
And of course, all of these predictions turn
out to be wrong and we get more traffic and
more noise and more accidents.
And the pollution is not so visible, but it's
still just as problematic in the form of particulates
and carbon dioxide.
But what's interesting is that the original
way that this is portrayed is as horseless
carriages.
In other words, it's in a negative way.
So we take away the the horse and our problems
go away.
And now, a century later, we're a bit more
than a century.
We recognize that that our car based transport
system is also unsustainable for environmental
reasons.
And again, there's this sort of apparently
simple fix, which is fine.
We just make everything electric and we make
everything driverless and we've kind of fixed
it.
And I think we the risk is that we fall into
the trap of like, you know, if we just change
that one thing, everything else will stay
the same.
And the story at the car shows you that that's
not the case because changing from horsedrawn
to vehicles to cars had all of these unexpected
consequences.
And I'm sure the same would be true if we
tried to just apply one of these fixes.
So what I'm really arguing for in this book,
what I think is going to happen is that we're
going to have less of a monoculture in urban
transport.
We had a monoculture based on horsedrawn vehicles
than we have in many parts of the world, a
monoculture based on on cars.
And I think what we're moving towards in the
future is much more of a mixture of modes
of transport.
So not just busses and public transport, but
things like bike rental, ride hailing scooters,
cycle lanes, more walking.
I mean, just all of these things.
And I call this the Internet of motion.
And the reason I think this is kind of a much
more feasible alternative to to using cars
for everything than it used to be is because
of the smartphone.
And what the smartphone allows you to do is
knit together all of these different transport
modes so you can say to your phone, I want
to go from here to here.
And it will say, well, there's a bus arriving
in two minutes at the end of the street.
So take that.
Then get off and then get onto a scooter or
a ride, hail or something like that, but you
could actually integrate all these forms of
transport in ways that you couldn't before
we had smartphones.
So in that sense, the successor to the car
and car based.
So transport culture is the smartphone, but
if it allows you to combine all these other
things.
So the idea that we just kind of have to go
all the way, we all now, but with electric
motors instead of internal combustion engines,
I think is a simplistic, but I think it's
wrong.
Speaker 1: One of the things that I'm curious
to get your thoughts on is that both when
it comes to automobile travel and air travel,
it's sort of been a while since there's been
a real paradigm shift in it getting significantly
faster.
Now, I don't think the most important thing
is speed.
And there's this obsession with speed and
efficiency.
But I think it's it's an interesting topic,
which is when you consider, you know, OK,
vehicles today may have a higher top speed
than they had 50 years ago.
But due to congestion and due to so many other
things, you're effective.
Traveling speed in a vehicle is not dramatically
faster than when the highways were first built.
That was a big advancement, highway speed
as well.
Speaker 5: And it's eight miles an hour, so
it hasn't taken a toll.
Right.
Speaker 1: Right, when it comes to air travel,
we had this phase where you had the Concorde
supersonic, but it was very expensive and
inefficient and loud, and now United Airlines
has committed again to supersonic.
But basically, you know, planes have basically
been going five hundred and fifty miles an
hour for a very long time now.
And it seems out of sync with the dramatic
advancement in so many other areas, computer
processing, speed, et cetera.
What do you make of that?
Speaker 5: I think it's a logistical thing
so that if you look at the era when Concorde
was running, so Concorde could basically do
London to JFK and, what, something like three
hours.
Right.
Instead of instead of six or seven.
So but if you actually if you're somewhere
in London.
So here I lived on the other side of London
to east London.
So it would take you at best it would take
me an hour to get to Heathrow Airport and
I probably should allow two.
And then obviously I have to check it two
hours before the flight and I've got to go
through security and all that kind of stuff.
So basically, I have to leave four hours before
the plane takes off.
Then when I get to JFK, I have to stand in
line maybe for a couple of hours to get through
immigration.
I mean, it has been I mean, it varies.
You know, even if you've even if you're flying
at the front of the plane, you get off the
plane, you if another plane planes come in,
that there may be there may be a lot of you
may have to wait for your luggage.
Then you have to get into Manhattan, which
is again and you find a cab.
And I mean, I like I tend not to take a cab
because it makes me feel ill.
So I prefer to take the air train to the subway.
But they get that takes you an hour to get
to the to the to the to midtown.
So so, again, you're you're looking at basically
a whatever that is, 12, 15 hour process and
the Concorde takes kind of four hours off
the middle back.
That's right.
That's not really affecting me, given how
much more expensive it is.
It's not really affecting the overall door-To-Door
travel time that much.
And so the number of people who are prepared
to pay, you know, that much more money to
just take a take three or four hours off the
middle of a 12 hour process was not a big
enough to make it work.
And we'll see what happens with this new generation
of supersonic planes.
But I mean, the I you can't fly supersonic
over land.
So they're trying to come up with various
fixes for that.
But if there's one route to the world it was
going to work on, it would be London, JFK.
And that was the route that Concorde was most
effective, although it didn't add up.
So.
So, yeah, I think the thing to watch out for
here and I don't go into this in the book
because it's it's not about wheels, but it's
this idea of suborbital transport.
And this is something that Elon Musk has talked
about.
I mean, people have talked about this for
ages, but he's actually building a vehicle
now that that may even fly the next few weeks
that we might see doing this.
And this is where you basically launch a rocket.
But instead of going into orbit to start to
get if you go into orbit, the space station
orbits about once every 90 minutes.
If you get into the lowest possible Earth
orbit, you're going around the world once
every 90 minutes.
And another way of looking that that is if
you lock yourself into an orbit that doesn't
quite it doesn't quite make it into orbit.
So it's just suborbital and then comes down
on the other side of the world.
You'll get there in 45 minutes to an hour.
So this is the idea that you could fly from
pretty much anywhere to anywhere in less than
an hour if you took a suborbital trajectory.
And the starship may be able to do that, then
you've got this big problem again, if you
have to build space ports outside cities and
Moscow is talking about floating space ports.
And so so that's that's a potential game changer
in terms of those things.
But I think we're still going to come back
to you know, I like to say, even if we build
hyperspace tunnels from London to New York,
you're still going to have to have security
around them.
You're still going to have limited capacity
and you're going to have to go to the hyperspace
port, which is probably on the other side
of town.
So then you then your London to JFK, you know,
maybe you can maybe you can take a few hours
out of it again, but you're still looking
to get down to zero and you can have that
technology at everyone's homes and you could,
like, step through your hyperspace port into
your holiday home in another country that
I can't see that that can't see that working.
And we don't even know if this is possible.
So so, yeah, I think it's a very good point
that actually these boring logistical constraints
actually end up being the most important factor.
Speaker 1: We've been speaking with the book's
author, Tom Standage, who's deputy editor
of The Economist.
Tom, really a pleasure speaking with you today.
I appreciate it.
Speaker 5: Thank you.
Thanks for having me.